nous ne sommes plus qu'heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec des participants qui sont devenus
des stars grâce à cette émission il
n'arrête pas de faire des selles fille
de signer des autographes
bon autant vous les présenter tout de
suite voici laurent garin
jean-patrice bonjour vous ne pouvez plus
sortir deux autres mais bien non c'est
très compliqué pour nous mais voilà on
fait comme j'ai déjà regard méchant et
ça c'est ça aussi le reconnaissent
laurence mercadé qui se terrent au
palais de justice de versailles avec des
scènes et qu'ils reconnaissent mustapha
larbaoui voit la trappe
j'ai aucun mérite donc à mairie parce
qu'en fait les gens m'abordent
simplement pour dire tu feras une grosse
bise à patrice même vous était déjà une
star dans mon quartier claire monde se
connaissait tous les uns les autres
tous comme c'est bien félicite andy hall
tournée ravi de retrouver tout va bien
mais oui c'est un plaisir de revenir
aussi de retrouver tout le monde
nouvelles lunettes non rester une star
humble et et jean charles lajoie dit un
jeune éditeur toujours éditeurs avec un
nouveau livre qui s'appelle dieu 2.0
sera votre dernière parution
on en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure
puisque on va aborder les prix
littéraires donc on en fera une petite
séquence sur sur la littérature vous ne
parlerez d'ailleurs d'un livre qui n'est
pas une grosse et pas boussole mais qui
traite un peu le même sur la même
thématique sur la culture
c'est donc henry duboc dieu 2.0 c'est un
livre d'anticipation puisqu'il n'y a
plus un pape mais le pape s mal à ça se
passe en 2050 et c'est assez astucieux
et très très intelligente
ça raconte un peu le combat et de la
difficulté à continuer à croire ou ne
pas croire avec internet et les
nouvelles technologies et le héros est
un type assez amusant qui a inventé un
cimetière virtuel rideau revendra parce
qu'il ya plus de place dans les
chaumières donc on va sortir
virtuellement
on va commencer par quelque chose qui
est un peu différent la littérature
c'est la sphère benzema valbuena vous
savez d'affaires de la sextape de
valbuena qui auraient filmé sur un
téléphone portable qui aurait été
retrouvée par quelqu'un qui connaissait
benzema benzema roth il était
l'intermédiaire entre cette personne qui
voulait faire chanter
valbuena et et le joueur de football
gbagbo lui même
on en est là benzema était en garde à
vue il est mis en examen ça veut pas
dire qu'il est coupable d'ailleurs
qu'est ce que vous pensez les uns et les
autres de cette erreur du ce que ça nous
dit au fond de la mentalité du football
des footballeurs gagnent en charge je
suis inquiet pour la la la présomption
d'innocence parce que pour l'instant il
n'y a rien sur benzema enfin nous moi je
ne sais pas
il n'a rien fait il est juste un peu
un peu curieux de sûrement dans ses
relations dans ses fréquentations ce qui
fait qu effectivement on peut toujours
se poser la question de est-ce qu'il a
un peu menacé
valbuena vous permets moi je pense que
il faut attendre un petit peu et je suis
un petit peu choqué par tout les
réactions de beaucoup de d'élite oriali
d'un énorme dose de football et qui
comprennent les racailles à en envoyer
tout le monde à cayenne en dix ans ce ne
sont que des racailles génération
racaille des truands des incultes des
abrutis vont faire ce sont des joueurs
de foot ya effectivement dans le lot des
racailles des abrutis en action il y en
a qui sont très sympas et avantages se
taire c'est sait que le foot est comme
le monde qui nous entoure et autant de
cons dans le foot que claquent ailleurs
ni plus ni moins et voilà donc la plus
d'argent c'est assez étrange alors je ne
sais pas du tout si benzema a participé
à de quoi que ce soit mais s'il a
participé ce serait pour recevoir pas
vingt mille euros vous disons à peu près
c'est à dire ce qu'ils gagnent à peu
près en deux heures c'est ainsi que je
vois c'est que si ce n'est pas pour
l'argent enfin 5000 euros par mois on
voit pas pourquoi on monte un truc qui
va rapporter effectivement 20000 euros
l'autre truc qui est assez curieux ça
c'est vraiment l'heure le monde du
football et associés devant de
particuliers et d'unique c'est que les
footballeurs alors peut-être le mustapha
nous en dira plus semble avoir une
passion pour les portables
ils ont tous cinq ans portable mais 50
portable 12 numéros par exemple pour
jouer alors des portables des voitures
je pourrais jouer le meilleur benzema ou
cissé j'ai essayé en tant que
journaliste quel point vous passez par
12 numéraire vous avez tous les frères
tous les trucs qu'on peut pas il n'y a
pas que vous essayez de joindre me de
françois hollande il ya un numéro puis
on tombe sur ça c'est une personne et
puis on peut lui parler
s'il veut bien vous parler mais benzema
ou cissé ou les grands footballeurs
c'est un week-end de trucage d'un rappel
à ce numéro à telle heure et ses
références c'est que ça va bien
différence en appelant le président ce
moment là parce qu'on a besoin d'argent
il en a pas en revanche un jeune
allemand eon parce que les copains c'est
ça on peut donner du pognon aurait selon
la ligne je me dis que le nombre de
téléphones qu'ils ont il doit y avoir
beaucoup plus qu'une c'est que voilà il
y en a partout et ils ont raison quand
même aussi une tendance au sexe et
dépanner mais faut avoir le bras long
pour fait une sorte de celle-ci sextape
avec sa femme qu'il connaît bien pour
répondre à la question
patrice sa dîme pour moi ça dit
absolument rien sur le football parce
que le football c'est bien évidemment
pas cette chose ça dit beaucoup de
choses sur les gens qui ont de l'argent
ça dit beaucoup de choses sur les gens
qui sont connus ça dit beaucoup de
choses sont on va dire les vedettes et
on aime bien à la fois ce type
d'histoire à la fois les des histoires
quand ça fonctionne bien on a besoin
d'enfoncer les uns et les autres
surtout quand ça nous rappelle quelque
chose personnelle par exemple les
footballeurs dans les banlieues là où ça
joue essentiellement au football
ailleurs également voir des footballeurs
qui réussit c'est une manière de dire on
réussit aussi dans nos quartiers dans
nos cités dans les lieux où l'on
pratique le football et donc ça
s'appelait de savoir que quelqu'un
réussit de ceux de notre ville et en
même temps et en même temps tout le
monde sait y comprend aisément que
gagner beaucoup d'argent finalement pour
ne jouer qu'au football qu'à un moment
donné on peut tirer dessus
c'est une manière de dire mais
finalement une joue au football et
essadi encore une fois beaucoup de
choses sur le rapport qu'on a à l'argent
parce que c'est beaucoup plus simple que
ça en fait patrice c'est pas parce
qu'ils gagnent à les 600000 un million
je ne sais pas combien ils gagnent par
mois des basques qui l'a pas qu'il a pas
tout simplement les mêmes notions qu'il
a toujours eue avant de gagner du pognon
donc en fait il passe pas son temps à
regarder son compte en banque ou à
regard
et comme il a gagné lui le jour même
c'est qu'en fait quand il y en a une
histoire avec crois pas quand il est
relié à des anciennes connaissances
quand il est relié finalement à l'humain
mais il est comme tout le monde il
réagit alors il réagit plus ou moins
bien je vais pas commenter jeu là ils
sortent de centres en ce moment d'un
milieu voilà j'ai peut-être qu'ils ont
des copains qui étaient avant leur
réussite politique dès qu'ils sont pas
forcément tous extrêmement fermes et
viables mais encore comme ça c'est
encore une fois ça veut bien dire il est
désolant salyers c'est plutôt
sympathique
ils sont pas que or seuls parfois ça le
rêve de revenir dans les quartiers j'ai
pas la même rémunération mais je suis
régulièrement dans le quartier où je
suis où j'ai grandi
les gens de trappes les connaissances
que enfin les gens connus de trappes
reviennent également dans leur quartier
et finalement ses racines qu'on a dans
nos quartiers dans notre territoire dans
les endroits où on a grandi ben on a
gardé cette sensibilité aux uns et aux
autres
et des fois bah ouais les vieux réflexes
reprennent et s'est vu un naturel qui
reprend le cac reprend le dessus
c'est pas parce qu'on est riche qu'on en
oublie d'être celui qu'on a toujours été
sans les qualifier un genre mais au fond
ça devrait impliquer une conscience
parce qu'il est quand même représentatif
du monde du foot
il s'est quand même un nikon pour les
jeunes enfin on peut pas dire que il ya
certains travers et que finalement il
revient sur ses travers ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est quand même idée g
ça reste une image donc les forcément on
se focalise sur ce qu'il fait lui et il
doit quand même savoir que va y avoir
des conséquences sur ses actes oui c'est
sa combi c'est aussi comprendre
correctement c'est parce qu'il est fait
ou qu'il l'ait pas fait tu veux que je
veux dire c'est qu'il est tellement
médiatique que c'est normal que combat
il faire ouais c'est simplement frmn
travers forcément on en parle quoi comme
zidane qui a mis un coup de boule enfin
ce genre de choses ccmm csn autre chose
non mais j'en suis d'accord l'espagne
s'est fait choper à conduire sans péril
benzema donc mais ils n'arrêtent pas non
plus non mais c'est ça qui est dommage
il avait passé heureusement elle était
il avait plu je crois que c'est sur
l'idée
oui sur l'idée que ces gens là mais pas
simplement les footballeurs n'ont bien
sûr ce qui est très timide et il vient
d'en sont représentatifs d'une table
sont pas représentatifs il représente
que lui-même mais qui sont visibles par
là je suis d'accord qu'effectivement il
devrait y avoir cette conscience qu'à un
moment donné on est visible on
représente probablement probablement
mais encore une fois il faut parler sur
des faits oui c'est un coup de bol on
l'a vu et ça j'étais le premier le soir
du match en disant que c'était
catastrophique pour l'éducation dans le
nom c'est dans cette affaire là moi je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé on avait
bien sûr il est pris en revanche il est
il reste une icône pour pour les uns et
les autres parce que il n'est pas comme
ça sans avoir bossé pardon de la
négation
parlant du travail de ces gens là ils
sont pas ce niveau là sans avoir nous
une intensité dans le travail d'une
intensité dans les dents les règles
qu'ils maîtrisent au quotidien que ce
soit sur le terrain ou à l'extérieur
et comme ça dérape ça dit plus quelque
chose sur les gens qui aiment voir ces
gens là dérape et que sur ce qui va
réellement parce que lui et tous les
hôtes à ce haut niveau
je parle des sportifs en général que ça
soit le football basket où tous les
autres sports à ce niveau là il ya de
l'abnégation à ce niveau là ya du
travail à ce niveau là et là on peut en
parler de ces gens méritants mais la
menace est en fait la question de
laurence et est ce que ce niveau là
aussi ne devraient pas être des exemples
vous avez déjà deux et c'est ce que je
viens de ville de brest mais je sais pas
ce qu'il a fait dans cette affaire cela
donnerait bien si ce n'est de l'entente
bien cela dit ça ne dérape pas qu au
niveau parce que là en essonne ya plus
ils ont annulé tous les matches de
niveau amateur ce week end parce qu'il
ya un dirigeant qui a agressé un arbitre
donc améliorée dans le business
il a des tests mais sur le football
alors ce qui s'est passé parce que je
fais partie de la commission de
prévention c'est remonter jusqu'à notre
commission effectivement on prend des
mesures disciplinaires parce que quand
il ya deux millions de gens qui
pratiquent le foot c'est le principe de
la télé et c'est un peu le principe non
pas de cette émission justement montrer
un peu de recul et on peut parler des
choses sur le fond c'est que
effectivement quand il ya une anecdote
on en fait un effet de loupe tellement
intense qu'on jette finalement le propre
sur les 2000
oui ce qui est arrivé est vrai c'est un
arabi qui a été agressé et les
toulousains les gens tous les arbitres
ont décidé de ne pas jouer ce week-end
en distrayant et non pas en ligue
pour marquer le coup comme par exemple
il ya dans les entreprises par exemple
de transport à l'essai est fou dans
l'est la ratp ou des fois il ya un droit
de retrait ou quand il ya une agression
des uns et des autres l'entreprise dit
nous on se met en retrait il veut le
dénoncer il ya eu des prises donc ça va
vous l'avez compris ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça arrive dans le monde du
football comme ça arrive partout
simplement ces incidents là on les
traite on bosse dessus ou prendre des
mesures et on fait en sorte que ça ne se
reproduise pas mais quand ils sont
avérés
là en l'occurrence jeu pour prendre sa
défense en ont mais c'est mon avis a dit
rien sur le foot pour l'instant sur
d'innocents ce que vous dites là ça dit
effectivement des difficultés qu'on
apprend on y travaille
j'ai presque me dire aux téléspectateurs
que finalement rassurez vous quand il ya
quelque chose qui se passe et qui est
finalement m'ont mis en exemple qui est
montré du doigt qui et qui fait un effet
de loupe
ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de choses qui vont bien aussi même dans
le football n'a pas entraîné mais les
femmes
cette histoire c'était que djibril cissé
disent qu'ils étaient coutumiers du fait
et que en fait la cagoule et fois le
maître la sadc des costumes et du
chantage donc ça serait pour une faille
en à main qui est allé voir la police
parce que tout part de ça en fait un
bond histoire est une région la première
maison payée et moi c'est ce qui m'a le
plus étonné c'est à dire qu'ils
connaissent à restaurer ce n'était pas
quelque chose d'aussi spectaculaire et
c'était la première fois que quelqu'un
était allée voir la police
mettez le doigt dessus et ne lâchait pas
la faire et c'est ça qui fait que
maintenant ça avec la paix quand on fait
de sextape parce que c'est pour pour
être vu ou pas d'ailleurs
on savait que ça l'a fait lors des bas
sur la sphère lui sa défense benzema
c'est de dire qu'effectivement il a été
en contact avec valbuena mais à titre de
conseiller mme moyal
voilà donc là un conseil amical il n'y a
rien de pénal
non mais enfin bon maintenant il est
bien les trois personnes qui sont en
détention provisoire ils ont été en
contact j'ai eu des appels téléphoniques
au moment de cette affaire là donc il ya
quelques indices qui laissent à penser
qu'il n'est peut-être pas si clair bon
maintenant je pensais surtout didier
deschamps tu as un problème puisqu'il
n'a le droit à l'eau ça la rend bien ils
sont par l' agence
ils sont pas loin de se contacter
contact et dont les choisit des liens
dynamiques ce n'est ni l'un ni l'autre
ce qui peut-être de dire autre chose
puisque du coup ben arfa arrive en
équipe de france mais désigné combien
est-ce que c'est juste moi hier pour
valbuena qui est donc dans la sphère et
sur la victime
ces victimes portent plainte il est
comme celui qui est censé être
cela dit ce responsable à ça reste des
sélections pour des matchs mais il ne
fait pas de film qui n'apporte si si si
si les matches amicaux anciens pas parce
qu'on cherche à trouver des schémas de
jeu pour des matchs importants
c'est un pansement mais le prochain
n'est pas un capital si je veux bien si
je peux éventuellement dire quelque
chose qui aura pas être dans le vrai
sens non par contre alors l'argument
concernant valbuena c'est pas ça c'est
qu'en fait c'est il est dans des
dispositions psychologiques qui
affaiblissent finalement qui
affaiblirait finalement ses capacités à
lui mais également à tout
l'environnement du groupe c'est vrai
qu'un groupe ça se gère quand même avec
des choses qui interviennent à
l'extérieur à l'extérieur des vestiaires
et tout ça ça influe sur le groupe donc
le mieux c'était de dire écoute tu te
mets à l'écart oscille entre parenthèses
en tant que benzema soit physique 1
c'est une blessure physique mal mais
démentant pouce blessé et on l'a vu
contre le psg par exemple était porté
par là c'était pas la même éthique non
plus je parle de jeu par le real de
madrid en revanche puisqu'on parle
football depuis tout à l'heure
profitons-en pour dire qu'on a vu une
très très très très belle défaite du psg
parce que franchement ils ont joué
extrêmement bien faire là bas au trapèze
hopper ils ont bien joué mais oui c'est
pas de chance on a bon plus là dessus on
a je crois qu'à peu près à peu près tout
dit on peut passer un autre sujet qui
était la présence de manuel valls je
crois que c'était devant les étudiants
de sciences po cette semaine et qui a
parlé un peu à corps ouvert qui a
enterré notamment définitivement en tout
cas jusqu'en 2017
le vote des étrangers aux élections
locales alors c'est une vieille promesse
presque un serpent de mer et qui a
commencé en 1981 1 580 qu'on ne peuvent
accorder le droit de vote aux étrangers
non européens puisqu'il est désormais
ils ont déjà accès aux élections locales
et on s'en sert un peu comme d'un
chiffon rouge des moments pour faire
monter le front national mais finalement
personne n'a jamais travaillé l'opinion
sur ce sujet qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez les uns les autres
ouais je suis mon conjoint de vote des
étrangers donc je vous êtes un homme et
j'adore les étrangers les jeux sont et
étrangers en a pas de raison il votait
jeudi aux élections locales c'est parler
des téléséries obama mais quels que
soient les noms parce qu'à chaque
fournisseur il ya quatre ans de
nationalité mais là il s'agit pas
d'actions nationales il s'agit
d'élections locales
oui mais d'abord c'était ça va être un
petit peu comme le pacs et le mariage
pour tous via ses on sait très bien
qu'on fonctionne par étapes
après on verra bien ou pas bien on sait
très bien que si on démarre par des
élections locales dans cinq ans ou dans
dix ans ce sera pour tous impliqués mais
pourquoi pas pour les président yahla
sexe de fleury et jamais de passage de
là
l'autre mais n'ont jamais dans évoluons
pas tout à fait comme tous les autres
pays
hélas ou tant mieux je suis abonné par
exemple si on veut voter ou devient
français et puis c'est tout je ne vois
pas du tout pourquoi mais je vois même
pas une seule locaux aucun des enfants
gitans nottingham et des élections
locales
donc ça voudrait dire que ça n'a aucun
intérêt ou toutes les élections locales
pour moitié des gens qui paient des
taxes d'habitation l'état de siège dans
la ville ces tracks est sûre abitibi
dans la ville mais je veux dire je pense
que moi ça me paraît quand même un petit
peu normes et qua non je puisse avoir
leur mot à dire ce qui se passe dans
leur vie donc on a un début de raisons
dont on peut participer à des tas de
choses nationalité on est français on
vote on n'est pas français on va te
passe pas grave mais c'est aussi ça un
italien en allemand qui vote aux
élections locales pourquoi est ce que un
marocain pourrait perdre les élections
locales
de la même façon j'ai beaucoup
d'habitués pourquoi déçu et loire ce
seuil se permettent de voter aux
élections municipales faisait arrêter ça
n'a aucun sens et alors ils suffisamment
la croatie 3 dont la mouche dans ce
convoi nous y sommes pourquoi je sais
pourquoi je peux pas vraiment vous
n'habitez pas je vais j'y vais souvent l
église y avait quelqu'un et puis je
passe mon temps à te regarde aller à
reims pas pourquoi est ce que je n'aime
pas mon avis sur la façon dont la ville
de reims est gérée en vacances en
bretagne
qu'est ce que je fais ce que je peux pas
voter en bretagne aussi mais vous vous
avez ce droit mais votre parti
je pense que je pense que jean charles a
tout dit tout à l'heure que tous nous te
dis pour que tout le monde puisse penser
exactement le contraire c'est bien ça
c'est qu'en fait c'est une telle il ya
une telle confusion sur le sujet voilà
pourquoi si je vais en bretagne je peux
pas voter endroit pas si je vais à
marbella
de la même façon sauf qu'on ne parle pas
de voter n'importe comment
on ne parle pas de voter sur n'importe
quoi stratégiquement c'est noir ne pas
faire voter
tout le monde j'ai envie de dire parce
que règle fait de dire vrai les
étrangers mais s'agit pas de faire voter
des étrangers c'est l'histoire et aider
des gens qui sont dans la citoyenneté
intégré sur un territoire
alors c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas la
citoyenneté française et là-dessus
effectivement on peut on peut débattre
finalement du cadre juridique on peut
débattre finalement du périmètre sur
lequel on peut s'entendre mais
stratégiquement c'est une erreur de
penser que les gens qui sont sur un
territoire ne sont là que pour consommer
sur le territoire ne sont là que pour
finalement alors a priori on peut même
rajouter que pour le lötschberg
car les étrangers parce que on a
l'impression que les étrangers sur calme
on a l'impression que les étrangers sur
un territoire c'est toxique alors qu'en
réalité ils peuvent l'être certains le
sont des locaux égalé nature et loisirs
et les nationaux également sauf qu'on ne
retient que ça alors qu'en fait il ya
qu'elle ment autre chose j'ai presque
envie de dire arrêtons mains de les
contrats veille puisque ils sont tous à
l'identique stratégiquement c'est pas le
droit de vote aux étrangers qu'on
devrait revendiquer c'est le droit de
vote pour tous sur des sujets
extrêmement brésil auprès six en tout
cas compte au moins comment dire un
caractère le calme
c'est juste faire participer les gens et
qu'on fait participer les gens voulaient
responsabiliser d'autant plus les
probablement que dans certains
territoires c3 concentration 50 % soit
côté faire participer les rémois
l'abstention n'est pas efficace tout cas
je continue et je continue je dis pas
que ça va régler le problème
j'ai dis simplement qu'on ne pourra pas
dire à ces gens là que vous n'êtes pas
responsabilisés avec le problème quand
le vote existe parce que à la limite
stratégiquement c'est peut-être même un
élément important que de leur dire vous
êtes responsabiliser vous ne pouvez pas
dire vous êtes exclu non plus alors que
là ils ont tout le loisir de dire je
suis exclu fut pas responsabilisés on
met pas dans la dans le débat public
donc du coup je revendique sachant que
j'ai pas les mêmes droits alors je me
radicaliser tu sais je dis pas que c'est
la solution à tout non plus changeant
simplement
stratégiquement c'est une erreur faux et
ça fait juste flipper tout le monde ça
fait flipper parce que vote des
étrangers ça veut dire supranationalité
envahissement renouvellement et c'est
tous les termes qu'on l'entende en clair
ce qui est amusant c'est que plus de
gens sont pour les intégrations et plus
ils sont contre le vote de cette rolls
naoui parce qu'une radicalisation
allemande on est pour l'intégration en
pensant que les intégrer les assimiler
où ces corps et bien un problème sauf qu
enfin l'organisation de deux pour dire
linverse donc du coup même valls sapso
été son truc le pire mais il peut pas il
est tétanisé par les hommes et les
femmes et c'est intéressant voir ce
qu'ils ont déclaré aux élèves de support
des 10 on va pas continuer comme ça en
gros parce qu'on va dans le mur oui un
pour modifier la constitution emploi on
peut pas donc faut faire un référendum
et si on fait un référendum pour l'heure
non parce qu'il ya plein de gens charge
ce n'est pas ce que les gens voteront
pour tous a proclamé votre fils votre
autre chose voilà enfin fait random oger
poids pour jamais la question qui est
posée
oui mais là exactement voilà donc donc
il dit on arrête
il a utilisé le terme de totem t-bonds
qui voilà maintenant non c'est une
affaire classée
moi je trouve que alors venant de
donnant de la gauche si on veut
poursuivre juste c'est qu'ils ont
abandonné toutes les promesses ça se
trouve là toutes les valeurs de la
gauche jacobellis râle un peu d'ailleurs
bah oui non mais ça je comprends qu'il
puisse qu'ils puissent râler quand on
est un de gauche je suis celle qui
changent pas d'avis c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça c'est
une question qui fait tiquer qui clivent
qui crie ce qu'il fout les jetons pour
dire les choses simplement
il n'y a pas de réciprocité puisque moi
j'ai envie de dire aussi par rapport à
ce que des gens là où il a raison sur un
point c'est que effectivement tu
pourrais pas aller voter vous ne
pourriez pas aller voter à maghnia waouh
je la si vous y habitiez donc là il n'y
a pas de réciprocité dans ces mêmes pays
puisqu'on parle des étrangers non
communautaires
donc c'est vrai que la france sonne
d'orgueil ray
samba faye d'aller vers des notions une
plus universaliste mais encore une fois
tout en gardant à un cadre national
important pour ne pas risquer de perdre
finalement mais leur pardon si un maire
est quelque chose de très important
en quoi le député n'est pas quelque
chose d'aussi très important alors si on
peut voter pour le maire pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas voté pour le
député parce que c'est une question ici
de bien sûr que ce ne sera que le droit
de vote nationales soit le ghana
nationalité l'avion l'argent distribué
non mais il n'y a pas il ya un élément
structurant du vote contre les cas pour
lui donner une consistance c'est l'impôt
l'impôt sur le revenu l'impôt une
nationale or seul un pont entre contre
votre argument parce qu'il paye ses
impôts nationale
oui mais justement justement justement
justement non mais justement j'étais
parti pour dire que philippe hey déjà un
impôt national sans avoir le droit de
vote son plan national et pourtant on
peut déjà il revendique comme en son
genre tandis qu'on sent bien sanglant
mais park où il peine également des
impôts ça m'apporterait ouverte de
régisseur la région sur le département
mais également locaux et c'est sur cette
imposition là qu'on a envie d'avoir une
apposition de témoignages laurent il ya
quand même une question c'est comment ça
se fait je ne disais qu'on a commencé à
en parler en 1981 1 c'est à dire que
c'est pas tout à fait y est et comment
on n'a jamais préparé au fond l'opinion
à ça c'est peut-être ça le vrai problème
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que voilà
c'est si on fait un référendum et
finalement on veut tailler quelques
années 60 les français étaient pour un
oui là c'est ça maintenant on est plus
dans le conte donc c'est peut-être
parier une démo n'est rien mais sinon
moi je pense que chaque personne qui
apporte à la cité doit avoir droit de
vote
enfin la vue que ces îles sont ils font
partie entière de la ville locale ils
doivent avoir une influence sur la vie
locale je pense que voilà au moins
d'être pas représentatifs de la paix
dernière en cette 7e manche amour contre
un compte et c'est le contribuable qui
en portent
les yeux des français moi ce qui me fait
peur triste c'est vous qu'on vous dit
depuis 80 on n'a pas préparé les gens
non on n'a pas à préparer des gens comme
si c'était une éducation il fallait les
noms dans les décès on peut préparer une
opinion un peu on peut travailler mais
on s'en est servi par dont on s'est
servi du vote des étrangers en 88 01 est
servi pour faire monter le front
national contre la droite ait su à
chaque fois la gauche on est servi pour
faire remonter le front national des
chaque fois ça a été une sorte de
chiffon rouge qu'on va agiter on
pourrait traiter le problème autrement
que comme un chiffon rouge puisque la
déclaration de s que la déclaration de
vannes juste avant les régionales c'est
justement pas pour contrer un tout petit
peu le front national nous ont l'effet
inverse
même si l'effet inverse et par minute et
il a aidé saïda faire des signes il a
pas intérêt à ce que le front national
monte aussi ça dans ce cas la famine qui
disent qu'ils allaient le mettre dans
saab des étrangers pourraient ils
compteraient pour ça que la gauche se
dire on abandonne peu à peu tout au
tabloïd
mais pour être encore concret parce que
finalement cédé on parlait assez des
sentiments c'est des fantasmes pour moi
ce n'est pas une réalité et surtout
stratégiquement ce n'est pas une bonne
chose mais sur le territoire de sueur
trappe par exemple le taux d'abstention
est un des records
oui les normes nationaux à chaque
élection et en l'occurrence même sur le
plan le cam il ya trente mille habitants
sur la commune de trappes gens parlent
pour vous pourrez de son territoire le
taux d'abstention est beaucoup plus
important qu'ailleurs
par définition si on le rapporte au
nombre d'habitants et non pas aux gens
et pourquoi alors le taux d'abstention
est important par rapport aux capacités
de votation donc par rapport aux
inscrits mais par rapport au nombre
d'habitants parce qu'il ya une
population étrangère beaucoup plus
importante c'est à titre gracieux le
préciser le taux d'abstention ce juste
sur le nombre d'inscrits et il est très
fort le taux d'abstention parce que
quand je suis dans une famille de
nombreux temps parce qu étrangers moi
même je sens qu'une partie de moi même
et aix'qui jeunes m'exclure l2 fait même
ceux qui ont le droit de voter se
sentent marginalisés par les propres par
les siens dans une même cellule
familiale
donc il ya un taux d'abstention
important je parle bien d
inscrits on parle du taux d'abstention
jean-charles en revanche sur l'eau mais
au niveau statistiques sur la population
générale le ton d'autant plus important
donc on voit bien qu'on a un territoire
de 30000 habitants où il ya finalement
combien de personnes qui votent pour une
personne qui doit aller représenter le
premier magistrat de la ville et c'est
là qu'on peut se poser des questions
encore une fois tu que les territoires
soient représentés représentatif
encore une fois j'insiste ces stratégies
encore et pourquoi c'est si si on
pouvait penser que le l'accord de vote
aux étrangers changerait le le
pourcentage d'abstention ce qui est pas
tout à fait sûr non plus mais je viens
de donner un argument qui est celui que
même ceux qui ont la capacité de voter
ne vont pas nous autres pas mais jeudi
bien que dans la galerie c'est ce qu'ils
elles obligeront à minima a minima quand
on est supérieur à minima on a le taux
d'abstention nationale donc allez-y ali
il ya les effets nationaux sur le vote
mais là pour le coup j'essaie
d'expliquer le côté supérieur d'un vote
sur ces territoires qui à mon avis
s'explique aussi en partie pour ça mais
impliquer les gens ça jamais fait de mal
à mon avis puisqu'on parle de démocratie
locale
florence merkel est ce que vous pouvez
expliquer un mejia mike comrie combien
de fois on peut renouveler deux fois
est-ce que ça ça vous paraît terrible
pas que de mise du travail ne sache pas
répondre à une question un peu basique
quand même c'est quasiment monstrueux
mais sinon c'est du même domaine que
fleur pellerin qui décrivent alors qu on
se demande à quoi servent les myriades
de conseillers qui sont fort bien payé
qui les entoure ce n est pas l a pas
croisé bourdin dans la rue qui lui a dit
tiens allez monte on va faire un petit
un petit interview non je verse et c'est
décidé c'est passé c'est prévu elle sait
bien qu'on va lui poser des questions
visiblement s'en fout c'est faux c'est
pas très grave mais de les conseiller
sur ce curieux
interview de vie porté sur le projet de
réforme bien sûr devant fallait un peu
mais non mais voilà c'est dit c'est dit
c'est quand même hein c'est vrai que
entre les atermoiements sur la fiscalité
cette incapacité à répondre à une
question quand même un peu basique ça on
se demande quand même comment je reçois
aussi des ministres enfin ils sont
choisis un peu visiblement sur leurs
montures leur apparence plus que sur ce
qu'ils savent ce qui est quand même un
problème non moi j'ai le théorie oui et
c'est papon t na s'est pas planté
si vous écoutez bien ce qu'elle a dit
pour l'avoir écouté mais c'est toujours
pareil ça passe vite pour l'avoir
entendu moi j'ai cru qu'elle avait dit
dès la première fois on a le droit à
trois cdd
ça fait bien ça fait bien de
renouvellement de renouvellement c'est
quoi c'est un cdd renouvelable deux fois
donc assez d'aidé
je signe je leur renouvelle de soi ça
fait bien trois matchs en main sur
l'intérêt à tomber quand je rendais
réserve en géorgie quand j'ai énormément
quand j'ai une ordonnance 2 avec deux
renouvellements jan agha un
renouvellement du marché
c'est là la preuve je cherche pas la
défendre parce que là pour leur faire ce
raisonnement c'est l'armée aminé mon
raisonnement il va jusqu'au bout c'est
pour moi elle a raison de dire que ces
trois fois maximum puisque c'est une
fois renouvelé deux fois
sauf qu'à mon avis elle a tellement bien
bossé cassé juste en et les pinceaux
austère qu'elle se souvenait que c'était
3 renouvelé deux fois un bon lui a pris
tellement de choses à ce que près de
vienne en brouille
mais elle a tellement baissé son sujet
qu'à mon avis elle en avait trop dans le
crâne s'est planté oui ils ont été dans
la manière de répondre à ces plantes et
mais elle avait bossé sur les temps pour
être encore plus sérieux gens
mais ça va être assez complète
attristante moi mon avis il faut éviter
les micros faut éviter encore une fois
c'est contexte là quand on n'est pas
encore au point
pour moi la pêche et surtout par naïveté
face à la question et la réponse est
assez embrouillée et en même temps
c'était peut-être pas c'était peut-être
pas le moment d'y aller on n'est pas
obligé d'y aller non plus et enfin pour
finir par contre il ya quelque chose qui
est ce qui est super inquiétant c'est
que moi depuis que je suis petit je vois
les gens de venir ministre et moi ça me
met ça m'épate parce que c'est
maintenant on met ça m'épate pourquoi
parce que quand je voyais prendre un
exemple de gauche et de droite
quand je voyais sarkozy qui était
ministre
du budget et que trois jours après il
était mise dans l'intérieur on le voyait
à l'assemblée nationale défendre les
dossiers comme personne je trouvais ça
admirable
quand ségolène royal était ministre de
peu importe il est devenu ministre
peu importe d'un ministère à l'autre on
les voyait à l'assemblée nationale
défendre leur dossier de façon
remarquable et là je me disais mais
comment on fait pour devenir ministre et
surtout comment on peut être ministre
est passé d'un portefeuille annonce ce
qui prouve bien qu'ils bossent et qui
sont aussi les insultes et les moqueries
tic à les représenter car il faut pas
visiblement ça se perd un peu ce qu'il
faut bien c'est qu'il ya des gens très
brillants
non mais c'est vrai que de plus en plus
c'est un casting qu à ça que nous on a
l'impression qu'il ya quand même un
casting les journées et donc du coup là
du coup elle est jeune elle était même
représentative mais le printemps de la
démocratie souvent c'est prouvé trop
présentes et donc on veut te représenter
par des femmes c'est la parité par des
hommes c'est la parité par des jeunes
par des des minorités en visite qui
devient une femme de la minorité visible
comme elle félicitée sauf qu'il y en a
des preuves iliad est visible des
minorités trop si je sais pas pourquoi
ils n'apparaissent pas seul à féliciter
ça vous a choqué les genres et les trois
fois c'est dd j'ai sorti mon arme à
renouveler deux fois voilà alors je vais
le garder alors envolé je suis un peu
perdu ou moi finalement la meinau sous
échoué deux fois alors c'est ça d'accord
tout ça pour en arriver à la réforme du
code du travail
c'est peut-être bouquet de nous en
parler flamand spa recalés on parlait
d'une grande réforme visiblement lassé
reporter dans les deux ans offert des
commissions elle touche et sur le sur la
durée légale de
ce travail c'est beaucoup de bruit pour
rien alors il ya deux ans il ya une
chose on va les attendre puisque c'est
début 2016 où il est question de
constituer un groupe de travail avec
badinter pour réécrire les 125 pages qui
concerne la durée du travail conditions
de travail rémunération ça j'attends ça
avec un peu d'impatience parce que c'est
coeur un peu le coeur du sujet alors
c'est pas que le coeur du sujet mais
c'est quand même assez importants
notamment sur la durée du travail et
voir ce qu'ils vont faire du rapport
combrexelle une sur les seuils d'heures
supplémentaires et de voir s'il va y
avait aussi vont pouvoir jouer est
touché ou pas notre homme ça car même si
on n'arrête pas de dire la durée légale
reste à 35 heures alors il peut rester à
35 heures mais si on fait des des
majorations d'heures supplémentaires à
10% et plus à 25% c'est une façon aussi
de toucher aux 35 heures et permettent
de travailler plus avec une rémunération
qui sera quand même beaucoup plus
contenue et moins chère pour les
entreprises donc ça j'attends de voir
parce que théoriquement c'est 2016 ça
cette réécriture des 125 pages alors de
voir ce qu'ils sont capables de réécrire
et parce qu'ils écrivent et plus lisible
tout digeste que ce qu'on a
ou serait-ce pas d'un ter qui présidera
la voilà c est alors après sur la
réécriture du code du travail je
souhaite bien du courage elle met ça
dans deux ans donc on aura peut-être ou
pas nouveau président de la république
sans visa en fait reporter ces élections
donc non c'est un peu beaucoup de bruit
comme répond rien oui oui pas d'autre
commentaire
est-ce que alors le ministre d'intérieur
cazeneuve annonce la fermeture des
frontières pour le prendra comme 21
cétacés ont bien évidemment le front
national sur précipitent là dessus en
disant mais attendez si on ferme les
frontières compte y est déjà important
ça veut dire que les frontières servent
à quelque chose
les raisonnements est assez raisonnable
même si même si la fin même si quand le
quand la conformation de 10 à y pense à
l'immigration alors que quand une
cazeneuve pense ferme les frontières
c'est pour éviter des débordements par
des groupes gauchistes allemand un
têtard des manifestations mais donc
c'est pas le bel mais c'est pas le même
but
voilà c'est bien évidemment pas le même
but après c'est ça va créer un précédent
évidemment excuses assez maladroit c'est
fermé pendant un mois après pourquoi pas
fermée pendant
moi à chaque occasion donc on peut
dessiner leur ferme et donc ça et c'est
un peu la mort de cette partie de
schengen ma connaissance c'est la
première fois que la france fait donc
qui a commencé ce que ce fait les
mesures provisoires ont cédé face que ce
n'est pas ce que je voulais dire donc
voilà ça risque d'être ça peut être
drôle mais pourquoi on n'a pas fait
cette coupe 21 je sais pas en lozère
aura deux noms mains d'un jeune laukyo
ya une personne qui ne vient sa mine
région peut-être au centre d'âge de
l'attention que lui demander pourquoi on
faisait la commune oui on peut faire
déjà affamés
mais déjà la ferrière pas ça va être une
une horreur absolue pendant un mois pour
les pour les parisiens même en ile de
france en est que la faire sa part dans
les yvelines il faut des lieux non
dropbox
il faut que ce soit une réussite bien
évidemment sur le climat ça c'est une
évidence mais il faut que ce soit une
réussite de circulation et de logistique
parce que ça va influer beaucoup dans le
choix de paris ou pas pour organiser des
amis parce que si c'est un bordel noir
et que plus personne ne peut bouger et
ses légendes des banquiers paris c'est
terminé on fera les jeux olympiques
n'importe quoi hier donc ils ont intérêt
à pas se couper là dessus et ça risque
d'être rock'n'roll à la nuance près
c'est que quand on fait des jeux
olympiques en général fait des villages
et les gens il reste il n'y a pas de
flux
alors que là il s'agit effectivement de
faire bouger des gens donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué en terme de logistique
sinon les sportifs on les mets la dans
des villages et puis il reste le même
praticien il ya peu qu'il ya peu de flux
ils sont ils sont mieux canaliser les
spectateurs ils viennent pas en
limousine avec les motards et comme les
chevreuils tard donc c'est bon là c'est
un petit peu à mon avis se tromper de
débat c'est important et quand c'est
important faut peut-être pas se poser
toutes ces questions là c'est majeur là
pour le coup il ya des questions
fondamentales sur la planète d'ailleurs
je supporte même plus moi cette idée de
réchauffement climatique la notion de
réchauffement
je demande à bastien déjà kantienne rock
quand vous avez une autre quand vous
avez un réchauffement personnel patrie
ça s'appelle de la fièvre et la fièvre
ou alors c'est pathologique
en l'occurrence on serait chiant
utilisons on serait chaud mais pas les
esprits jeanjean mais quand on a de la
fièvre c'est pathologique quand on a de
la fièvre on sait où ça peut
menés en termes de dégâts là en
l'occurrence on parle de réchauffement
de deux degrés de degrés de
réchauffement finalement ce n'est pas
plus mal
on a un hiver très doux probablement un
univers tout autant donc ça parle au
parc je me permets de sa part leurs amis
verts terrible si je crois les deux ours
de thoiry s'était calmé les conditions
les meilleures météorologues de d'europe
c'est à dire que dès qu'ils se préparent
à hiberner un peu tôt cette année creuse
l'albertaine ya beaucoup de vrai c'est
que l'hiver va être terrible mais ils ne
se sont jamais trompés
donc là il annonce à thoiry un hiver
extrêmement rigoureux taconnet voilà
c'est donc les images sont enregistrées
on en reparlera
et en l'occurrence non c'est juste pour
dire que deux degrés ça parle pas alors
qu'effectivement c'est vers l'insee vers
ses nuances mac il faut d'autres ont
tout ce qu on parle on parle de fièvre
laisser l'histoire du bouchon ni groupe
dubois canada et auguste raux qui en
coupe du bois et donc c'est pas c'est
pas un dos et un indien y passe et qui
fait aux hivers rigoureux
alors le titre i would ils ont un savoir
donc il coupe du bois encore plus et la
guerre pas fait hiver très rigoureux
donc ils coupent encore plus de moins
qu'en plus de moi le dernier repas
sévère très très très très rigoureux et
le lundi repassant dîner comment vous
avez ce ce savoir comme ça commence avec
il va faire ta voix lit parce que quand
blanc couper du bois hiver très
rigoureux
voilà excusez moi c'est l'histoire a
ajouté que le débat si on s'entre
uniquement sur les problèmes franco
français s'est passé afin la réussite de
la coop 21 savait pas être est ce qu'on
va réussir à circuler sur paris ou
dacquois n'ont question mais c'est après
si on n'a pas les jeux olympiques avec
la cap 21 est un vrai succès voilà je
pense qu'on va réussir
à son passé de tout ça mais voilà je
vous hais
mais après je suis pas sûr que l'opinion
soit totalement con se sentent
totalement concerné par la coupe 21 cela
commence vraiment faim ça y est je pense
que au niveau des gens se questionnent
enfin il ya des conférences ya pas mal
de chose qui s'organise autour de
l'implication des gens par rapport à la
coop 21 g t sur paris hier soir pour une
réunion à la ligue et je suis passé
devant tous les cafés de 2,2 de près du
louvre dans le premier il ya plus
personne dedans ils sont tous d'or avec
des braseros et du gaz qui chauffe la
rue chaude et ils sont plus nombreux et
ils sont tous bobos et quand vous les
interrogez sur la coupe sur la côte 21
sur les incidents du réchauffement
climatique tout le monde dira il faut
faire quelque chose c'est juste qu'il
filmait tous leurs clopes
dehors il y avait un monde de dingues
sur les trottoirs chauffée par des
braseros personnes dans les salles à
l'intérieur je me dis que à mon avis on
est mal barrés quand même ça serait bien
qu'on s'interroge on sait qu'on
s'interroge un minimum voilà c'est ça le
v12 une façon on est mal barré parce que
cette cette frénésie écologique si
sympathique soit est va nous amener à
être canalisée à des nouvelles
interdictions à des choses absolument
terrible c'est une espèce de laissac
l'agent de fascisme vert la dérive je
parle d' aberration ménager la cua mais
l'inscription mais le fascisme ouverte
et l'armé ça me paraît hasardeux dans
dix ans on te dira quand circuler
comment circuler où tu peux aller où tu
ne peux pas aller ça va ça va vraiment
être alors tout le monde a l'air de
prendre sans heurt bah oui c'est
sympathique c'est bien c'est pour sauver
les ours
ok très bien mais je n'ai pas se
manifester
c'est sur du très long terme
on parle quand même d'une dégradation
qui va aller mais c'est sur du long
terme
donc on ne peut pas se permettre de ne
pas se croire on sourit après je suis
arrivé il ya juste une chose est ce
qu'on est très bien informé parce que il
ya nous avons tourné au thon
scientifique qui vous disent on est dans
un cycle de la chauffe mans et l'action
de l'homme n'est pas forcément
majoritaire là dessus donc qui vous
disent ou le contraire si c'est l'action
l'industrie l'homme qui est qui qui
perturbe le clip a donc déjà il ya des
querelles scientifique
donc les gens se disent on est peut-être
pas forcément très informés comme comme
disait bustaffa aureilhan il disait
finalement un hiver plutôt plutôt
agréable faisait pas est passé pas si
mal que ça donc c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué à faire comprendre non je n'y
ai pas très long terme
et puis il ya tous ceux aussi qui
croient que la science pour avoir une
réponse aussi à ce genre de fenoyl vis
avec volkswagen ou si c'est à dire que
des résultats des recherches
on peut aussi se poser des questions
quelquefois à ce qu'elle serve et
quelles sont véritablement ce qu'il ya
derrière
un tout petit chiffre intéressant en
fait le tout ce qui est nouvelles
technologies informatiques et transfert
d'informations échanges d'informations
produit deux fois plus de gaz de carbone
les deux émissions carbone que le
transport aérien
donc voilà c'est intéressant pour la
réflexion parce qu'il ya des noms des
fermes complète de serveurs au pôle nord
pour enfin par exemple maintenant on
regarde plus les pages jaunes on regarde
sur google on a tous notre marque donne
et voilà au lieu de regarder un livre
vous regardez ses papiers là dessus
qu'il faut éduquer les gens et c'est pas
si tu veux si vous voulez n'est pas
question d'interdire ou de permettre à
quoi que ce soit c'est d'éduquer les
jeux il va être question est trop gens
de se sentir concerné intervient il y en
a déjà mais il faut qu'il est nécessaire
que les gens se sentent concernés par ce
qu'il pense que ça ne repasse pas au
dessus nous arrive à tous pas de source
et que je suis ravie si vous êtes très
riche et si vous pouvez vous acheter une
nouvelle voiture mais je ne les suis par
les jeux pour les trans comment devenir
gens qui bossent en marine et qui ont
des horaires assez difficiles qui
peuvent travailler des jeunes femmes qui
peuvent finir un boulot à une heure ou
deux
heures du matin et qui pourront rentrer
chez elles attrapent je ne sais où n'ont
pas d'autres moyens que de prendre une
voiture avec anne hidalgo et les verts
c'est maintenant enfin à part kim à
janvier s'est terminée et ne peuvent
plus rentrer qu'une voiture un petit peu
polluante dans paris ok c'est très bien
alors que vous allez mieux respirer mais
la pauvre nana comment il fait le garçon
de café comment fait-il pour se balader
c'est fini ici demain 10 astuces et les
espaces de réflexion c'est justement
l'inflation par le succès pour faire
réfléchir à des solutions comprend aussi
les des choses à l'envers quoi avant
dans paris pourquoi pas faire tous cas
l'une d'algos veut fermer d'abord dans
un premier temps ses maîtres des
parkings autour de paris c'est mettre un
maximum de transport en commun un
maximum de tramway on sort du parking
monde dans le métro dans un train
d'enfer plus exactement ne se soit pas
les moyens de faire ça va arriver dans
mais si on veut se donner les moyens de
réussir ce qu'elle veut faire il faut
d'abord en amont préparer à préparer les
chats sinon c'est comme bélise comme
vous dites à petit canal se retrouvent
pas rentré chez valve sauf qu'avec des
arguments comme ça revenons au début du
siècle dernier où des gens qui
habitaient la campagne on disait comment
voulez vous que ces gens là qui habite
la campagne n'ont pas de voiture pour
aller travailler à la ville
donc c'est très ajout sauf
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a une
bagnole ce qu'on dit maintenant c'est
qu'on peut également changer de
paradigme pour les cours et que ces gens
là qui sont loin à trappes dans les
campagnes puissent circuler en voiture
autrement que paul nantes mais c'est
compliqué jean-charles mais simplement
si on se donne pas des objectifs
par définition les atteindre a pas donc
c'est con hein c'est contraignent à
tueur polluants c'est un objectif qu'une
réalité et c'est en janvier 2007 une
vraie cure il ya cent ans moyen de créer
tout le crew d'une voiture il ya cent
ans
c'était exactement le cadre des voitures
que vous évoquez maintenant et on y est
arrivé et on doit y arriver et
l'allemagne et celle des gens qui du mur
de toute façon pas si mal
un des thèmes qui sera abordé dans le
festival du documentaire et il commence
jeudi
saïb line et les 50 animations qui ont
lieu tout à travers la vie nous
ouais donc c'est un gros festival on va
voir beaucoup beaucoup de documentaires
dont un certain nombre qui sont
consacrés à l'environnement y arriver le
documentaire d'ouverture de commentaires
de verture est consacré un seul à une
peule
c'est très éclectique vraiment très beau
choix de avec 220 réalisateur qui seront
qui seront d'ailleurs présents c'est ça
avec des auteurs aussi oui tout à fait
et la soirée d'ouverture c'est jeudi ses
taux au cinéma enfin à l'ugc salut c'est
oui tu fais bien de le savoir parce
qu'il faut que j'y sois
on va passer à un autre sujet puisque
j'ai fait un bide absolument terrible
avec l'histoire de ces biens nicolas
sarkozy alors et nicolas sarkozy qui dit
la justice s'acharne contre moi
évidemment son nom a été nommé cité dans
la sphère d'air cocaïne de manière
annexes puisqu'il avait emprunté le même
avion que celui qui transportaient la
cocaïne
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
acharnement ou est-ce que après tout
c'est une enquête qui se fait mais on ne
regarde fille qui a pris ont pas pris
cet avion il ya deux sources ont parlé
d'acharnement il faudrait savoir
je ne sais pas est ce que tous les gens
tous les clients de cette compagnie ont
été pistés téléphoniquement comme
sarkozy et je crois que c'est vraiment
un cas d'acharnement parce que seul
sarkozy était pisté
bon alors que si tous les clients ok ça
c'est normal ça c'est la première chose
deuxièmement et là je le pense encore
une fois vers florence ou totalement
scandaleux et les journalistes sont sont
là dessus du d'une légèreté enfin pour
vous pas dire pire c'est que non
seulement on écoute les les téléphones
de sarkozy met en balance la totalité de
ces conversations et tous les gens qui
là qu'il a pu contacter mais c'est une
intrusion dans la vie privée qui est
scandaleux c'est à dire que on sait
qu'il a appelée arthur on sait qu'il
appellerait ça on sait qu'ils appellent
machin casitas c'est scandaleux c'est
que ça
public voilà est-ce que c'est un rapport
avec la sphère que sarkozy téléphone
trois fois arthur
non aucun et les journalistes le mont
toulon se rengorge 210 il appelle arthur
il appelle carla bruni trois fois dans
la journée
y a quand même le droit d'appeler sa
femme quand il veut ça c'est vraiment de
l'acharnement et ça charmant qui n'est
pas que judiciaire c'est un acharnement
médiatique qui est totalement scandaleux
alors qu'ils instrumentalisent et oui il
ya le côté g10 ya là des médiatiques
c'est elle que je dirais enfin
mais voilà monsieur veut dire qu'un juge
vérifie il peut vérifier
enfin après on n'est pas forcé de le
savoir et puis après l'autre chose que
je trouve alors totalement
abracadabrantesque c'est le pouvoir qui
encore une fois dit nous ne sommes
absolument pas au courant oui valises à
jo willacy vraiment en france on peut
espionner un ancien président de la
république sans que personne ne soit au
courant alors on est carrément dans une
république bananière enfin je veux dire
c'est simple il n'ya plus d'état fait
les adjoints nantis en aucun cas été
porté avec la naissance du nasr de bien
faire à miller l'autre moi ça m'inquiète
mais à quoi sert le garde des sceaux à
quoi ce à quoi servent tous les tous les
gens qui nous gouvernent celles qui sont
même pas au courant c'est que c'est
quand même pas rien des anciens
présidents de la république nous reste
trois exercices ici on ne sait pas qui
surveille les nounous 3 présente et a pu
le trois ex présidents des enfants je
suis extrêmement inquiet perplexe et
curieux dans cette affaire il est
effectivement il ya une enquête avec une
instruction ouverte qui était ouverte à
marseille qui a été transmis via des
transferts à paris mais qui était
ouverte à marseille une pour abs dont
justement dans lequel sarkozy était
impliquée puisque dans cette enquête il
était question de reproché à stéphane
courbit d'avoir loué les jets à cette
fameuse société qui est impliqué dans
air cocaïne et de l'avoir mis à
disposition gracieusement à sarkozy
alors pas du tout pour la république
dominicaine mais pour atteindre dans
trois autres pays dans le monde
rien à voir avec la république
dominicaine et moi ce qui me choque
c'est que cette affaire tout d'un coup
elle ressort au moment où il ya cette
affaire d'air cocaïne avec avec ses
pilotes et c'est la conjonction des
choses alors que ça n'a rien à voir
qu'on est sur des sujets complètement
différents sites peut-être la même
compagnie aérienne
on n'est pas du tout sur le même sujet
pénale en tout cas que les choses
sortent en même temps et ça c'est une
faute
enfin je sais pas qui a fuité et pour
que ça sorte mais enfin je trouve que
des journalistes battus ils sont tombés
dessus
plus que la justice puisque la justice
est saisie depuis 2013 de cette affaire
d'abord c'est donc là que depuis 2000
presque sarkozy je trouve ça très
choquant effectivement parle
d'acharnement mais c'est peut-être pas
un acharnement de la justice mais là je
pense qu'il ya une faute des médias qui
est la montée en épingle et deux en
parallèle pourra pour faire du buzz
là où vous avez raison c'est que
quelqu'un qui écoute des informations un
peu de manière discrète il en sarkozie
air cocaïne
c'est pour ça qu'ils savent ah non ça
fait beaucoup d'histoires de ligne dans
cette affaire je sais pas si le tout
fait maison
mais je ne vais pas juger soit pas à
répondre franchement bien sûr c'est de
l'acharnement pour répondre clairement
la question bien sûr que c'est de
l'acharnement
c'est juste que ça dit encore une fois
beaucoup de choses sur lui on a parlé
des riches tout à l'heure cette fois ci
des puissants et du pouvoir
cela dit bien encore une fois quelque
chose sur la société et nous qui
regardons par le prisme de la télé et
donc par le biais du journalisme que
effectivement on s'intéresse souvent aux
riches et puissantes
quand ils sont faillibles et quand
souvent même quand ils peuvent tomber
donc oui c'est de l'acharnement
simplement s'acharne sur connerie on
s'acharne sur hollande on s'acharne sur
sarko on s'acharne sur une politique
globalement les deux sa faune et sa
charge les assauts sauf que ça grandit
personne parce qu'au final droite-gauche
un moment donné ça affaiblit tout le
débat politique on parle plus de la cap
21 a réellement devoir en parler on
parle plus des affaires qui réellement
pour la nation céréales d'ornans doubs
doubs mon débat en permanence sur l'idée
de lui-même ps et qu'on puisse mettre
autour de la table des gens qui font des
conneries
les uns et les autres mais qui peuvent
également trouver des solutions les uns
avec les autres
en clair beaucoup de com manque tout je
suis persuadé que beaucoup de gens de
choses à dire sur afer pardon
faire valoir surtout un mot sur les prix
littéraire puisque c'est la saison donc
on a eu le gros coup avec boussole de
mathias enard qu'il a lu moi c'est pas
un livre simple ne s'est pas encore
compliqué c'est de la littérature haut
de gamme permet cela dit que tous les
finalistes étaient étaient des cocos
assez compliqué et onéreux mais c'est un
pierre lemaître on peut pas entrer dans
ce goncourt comme et revoir là où tout
le monde l'a acheté tout le monde et
devant les quelques personnes parmi ceux
qui l'ont acheté l'ont lu quoi c'est ce
que la salle est un joli cadeau c'est
pas sûr que nous le voyons au moins
jusqu'à la fin parce que ce personnage
soit opiacées qui divaguent qui disent
grèce oui ça peut perdre un peu le
lecteur non mais je me suis perdue au
bout de quarante pas voilà j'ai eu 40
pages est pas qu aller plus loin je le
reprendrais quand même passer de la
cocaïne à l'opéra de sursis mais je n'ai
pas eu le loisir de commencé à
feuilleter quelques pages et au
contraire ça m'a happé tout de suite
j'aime son écriture trouve qu'elle a une
qualité hypnotique et justement ces
divagations je ressasse suis vraiment
très très vite et après 7 octobre de
lorient à sa part guy meurtre
je pense qu'une des raisons pour
laquelle il a été couronné c'est aussi
parce que ça ça dd rapport avec
l'actualité notamment la syrie enfin
donc oui aujourd'hui j'en fais encore
j'essaierai alors je serai ravie de
clients non c'est maintenant sept
personnes physiques c'est pas un bon
roman simplement que tu as vraiment
difficile voilà essais menés c'est ça le
truc il faut pas chercher à ça un
ancrage faut vraiment se laisser
entraîner
il faut combien il était assez
rapidement après non mais là le seul
candidat s'était posté enfin que le vrai
coq ans télé prépondérant qui a déjà eu
le prix de l'académie française et je
proclame le pnue
voulait pas donner cette année quelqu'un
vous prêt à quelqu'un qui avait déjà il
celui de l'académie française
un autre livre sur ce même thème que
vous nous recommander qu'il a fait sur
la même thématique qui est l'orient et
la culture orientale de 1900 à 1970
donc là c'est toute la vie de deux
chanteuses surtout kalsoum
ah oui mais voilà qui est une égérie
donc c'est un très très beau roman
illustré
donc en fait l'auteur a fait des jolies
gouache ce ne sont que des gouaches on
dira des pastels mais bon je sais pas si
ça transpire vraiment à les combler mais
enfin voila c'est un très très beau
roman illustré qui traite donc de cette
de cette chanteuse égyptienne qui était
l'égérie de la révolution et on voit
enfin même ibrahim maalouf sort aussi un
album sur une cale sous la voilà en ce
moment c'est vraiment la thématique à la
mode et ce livre est vraiment très très
beau et cette fois ci sur une petite
maison d'édition
et puis on s'appelle powell ah oui c'est
pas ça contrairement à ses pairs oui à
la question quand même représenté que de
0,2 point zéro mais roman d'anticipation
mais pas que ça se passe en 2050 et le
héros est le créateur d'un cimetière
virtuel il est dévolu dans un univers
que je crains un peu un univers où les
écolos on peut gagner la partie il ya
plus de papier donc ce qui me fait rêver
rapidement va signer à la mosquée et
voilà une pâte qui est une papesse iliad
est vraiment très content et une passion
voilà qui pose des questions sur une
déclaration à la réunion c'est merci
merci beaucoup à tous les 5es et j'étais
ravi de vous retrouver et j'espère qu'on
va vous retrouver très vite pour un
nouveau pont